Many proteins are modified by the
addition of a phosphate chemical group.
This process is called phosphorylation.
Why does this occur?
To function properly, cells must
regulate thousands of processes to
occur at the right time and place. They
have this control primarily by
regulating the activity of proteins.
One way proteins, like channels,
enzymes and intercellular signalling
molecules, can be controlled is through
phosphorylation.
A phosphate group is added to the
protein by an enzyme called a kinase,
which transfers a phosphate from ATP to
the target.
This phosphate group can be removed by
a phosphatase enzyme, making
phosphorylation, a process that can be
reversed. Whether or not a protein is
phosphorylated depends on whether there
are more kinases or phosphatases near
it. These levels can change within
seconds, which allows phosphoylation to
rapidly change the target protein's
activity. But how does phosphorylation
change the activity of a protein? First,
we need to understand a little about
what proteins are made of and how
they're structured. Proteins consist of
chains of chemical subunits, called
amino acids, which fold up on each
other to make a 3D structure. The amino
acids of a protein interact with one
another to form a structure with a
specific shape, and it is that shape,
which then determines the function of
the protein. Some of these amino acids
can be modified by phosphorylation, and
the addition of a negatively charged
phosphate group can affect how the
amino acids bind together. This can
change the 3D structure of the protein,
and therefore, its function within a
cell. All of these changes can modulate
cellular processes in many ways,
sometimes speeding them up, or slowing
them down, or even stopping them
entirely. Cell motion, division,
metabolism, and even cell death are all
regulated by phosphorylation.